feels better right it feels great
ding no can't even use that hey guys I'm
here in Chester see that's me now two
years ago Chester and I reviewed some BM
a fashion and I had a really great time
doing it that I thought this might be an
appropriate time to bring back a fashion
review at Chester City no yes cause two
years ago Miley Cyrus's but first is
Lady Gaga's but Lady Gaga has the
greatest ass of all time dad writes like
a beautiful scenario so there's like I
feel there's a missing piece over here
isn't it supposed to connect yeah oh my
god ha ha ha I usually did it and I said
what is this you would not say an ass
oh like a year and a half ago I guess
can they hear the dog chewing noises I'm
sure they can and then be really fun for
us review the Billboard Music Awards
fashions because you're a musician
explain to me musician what the
Billboard Music Awards are oh I no idea
JLo see a lot of her body that's her
thing right JLo really wants us to know
that she has a bellybutton and I don't
know why she needs us to know that so
hard if you just saw this you saw the
body with no head you probably like JLo
is that what I'm supposed to say yeah
yeah yeah I mean I was staring at that
thing for so long cuz I wanted to give I
wanted anything it's very well made
lemon like the dress that this image I
wanted to uh Nana will see if I if I can
be witty at all in it I think I should
there's no need to I know you I don't
know I yeah I already second guess
get hungry is the cameras on now I did
that's true I have nothing she look like
Hilary Duff right there
whoa yes Taylor Swift look at her doing
something original good for you that
looks like someone that's gonna win a
lot of wars I think yeah she looks
beautiful
where are her feet that's thank know
she's floating
Brian carry all right kind of you know
there's a theme with like you know if
your dress doesn't have some visibility
on the side or in a place that you don't
really think of typical dress having a
laugh cloth in that area now that
perfect one direction there's only four
cats move along there's supposed to be
five is alia it's like it's like do you
remember Kaboodle's of course you don't
Kaboodle's were were these like makeup
kits for young girls and that feeling
this is human Kaboodle's Kylie Jenner
Kylie Jenner you I think she I like this
dress a lot and I would wear it myself
yeah I really I mean I'm a I'm a fan of
Oh
finding why is this here's things like
are you doing the black and gold blue
and white game I was gonna make
something out of it but it's really
Ludacris he and Chrissy Teigen were
hosts of the show
I like it I like him I like his face
enough I can tell it is the expression
Calvin Harris Lane Wow
I love it fan of the skin any time but
it got shade eat in here I told you this
I feel like we've run out of options
with pants please give them your okay so
my thought is you know we're always
trying to change things up to make it
feel niphas mother's bail bond let's
make me wide at the bottom just make a
ruby baggy overall let's make them
really skinny I think the next tip is
like only one kneecap is really baggy
but flaps makes moving the next I'm glad
you got to air those grievances Lindsey
Stirling I think
looks god damn beautiful she does I
texted her the night of the award show
you look stunning I think I can say this
fairly objectively obviously we know
Lindsay Lea friend I think I would say
that's my favorite dress so far if I
didn't know
yeah Andy so it's not she actually
showing the scam but here's the thing
she got a ton of [ __ ] because everyone
thought that it was a see-through dress
and all of the black parts were the only
cloth areas but what happens with
dresses like these is there as an entire
unlike all of oh my god so all fabric
because she's a very modest human being
and likes to be covered head-to-toe
everyone assumed she wasn't and so she
apologized on Instagram which makes me
yeah set because she looked at you
beautiful and they mated about that
explained I was in this book if we were
in the Victorian era or you mean she is
showing a lot of ankle in that photo
how are you having but I we should hang
out sometime in way too long
David Lee Roth from Van Halen darling
fee this takes my best dressed someone
said to him in the morning they're like
they're like hey you might go golfing
but you also might drive a race car you
may go scuba diving but we also might go
to an award show so yes for both what is
your overall assessment of the Billboard
Music Awards what I should never be
judging fashion as we learned it here
and a half ago and it still holds true
today do a lot of fashion views so for
me I know how I want to judge this on
except for it felt like but it probably
should time but I don't get to just wear
whatever it whatever is most comfortable
because I have to buy by our cultural
standards like it's you know truly
that's why Lenny Kravitz you're cool
make sure you guys go check out just to
see across the internet he's doing lots
of things I'm tired of just managing an
Outback Steakhouse the awesome blossom
oh how dare you
is that how that yeah yeah I don't know
the rules
I'm trying to have an illusion of the
rules which is like
had definitive opinions about it because
I really shouldn't have definitive
things about fashion period right but
since a is the concept of your video
clearly both us should never have
definitive opinions about fashion
yeah that's true you look like you just
got off the clock from your lawyer job I
did and I just got off the clock from my
acid trip no big deal
I didn't even comment on it you knew so
overwhelmed by ur but not no well thank
you guys for watching don't forget to go
over to Chester Seas channel and look at
the sings the buzz good bye bye